Stevenson almost came up with a steal
here's James behind the back gets inside
sidestep Lance
first body of a powerful with the skill
level of a point dog
yeah and Sabonis has gotten the three
softest three files here to me that's
the and they're playing pretty well
without their best player and you stay
focused and not give please with the big
one if he games off the steel okay
okay birdies that's what he used to do
LeBron finishes strong on the paint
checks his rear view he knows he has a
shot blocker games quick spin lovin
throws it down in plays and at some
point in the other paces you got to make
the determination
[Applause]
that with three seconds left Cleveland
triggers in James two seconds
[Applause]
there is no play here bird this is just
one of the game's greatest players of
all time taking over
LeBron been inside the paint all night
long three seconds to go to pull up the
three and the celebration on in here in
Cleveland as they take the 3-2 lead 700
a Depot run Stephenson harassing James
thunderous dunk violation he did not
cross half-court spectacular play but it
should not have counted Toronto for the
Cavaliers see how them get switched on
no match the crank LeBron James great
pass by Lowry love with the block
James the first time
but then a step of the rim and I've come
up empty now if they're going to take
the charge or get the block here they
come again
going to be T everything's under three
second Rio throws up the floater on this
now
now once LeBron comes up on that left
side watch how he changes in the air and
gets it off the glass in plenty of time
now that was some play he hasn't taken
any off-balance
Ozzie goes up in the air he banks the
ball and plays it right off the glass
another moment indelibly etched in time
for the Cleveland Cavaliers and LeBron
James
[Applause]
Cavaliers can bring the lead to double
figures James behind the back
beautiful dish
10:01
brontosaurus felt like this could be
their year another look at was Ron James
it's like up James picks up his dribble
shot clock winding down James falling
away LeBron James 19 points already and
that's his fourth three-pointer this is
good defense this is a very good job by
Marcus smart but LeBron James just
feeling himself right now and he's a guy
that when he said he wasn't worried you
believe me chief point Cavalier lead
their largest of the series Morris
throws event Baynes goes inside blocked
by James right at the rim that's the big
veins that shot out of him a Iran he has
had some classic blocks
backdoor James throws it down perfect
bounce pass from Kevin Love and it's
back up to 20
this type of dump would take a lot out
of me also Mike spectacular past mile of
the big-time finish by LeBron James
mama there goes that man as high as 26
my speed hit stopping again he has had
some magnificent passes tonight
that's his ninth assistant keeping his
dribble and then just a beautiful left
hand wrap around turns it over but good
hustle back and he meets him at the
summit
backfires a three-shot short rebound
tipped and taken by James here comes
James in the open floor James ran from
behind goaltend one from James in the
open floor James
grabbed from behind goaltend it's up to
9 with 104 remaining LeBron James now
with 34 points absolutely amazing what
we're witnessing putting his team on his
back takes the contact hits the basket
put an incredible display by LeBron
James
mama their goals that men and they're
gonna look at flagrant foul here again
this crowd absolutely stunned
but that was a bad shot by Jalen Brown
again like trying to hit a home run with
the three down 7 and we got to give
criminal bar on James 5 to shoot Miggy
pokes it away James up and under
now Mike how about this play by LeBron
James great recognition great awareness
tremendous god-given ability